What's up, Jake?
>> What's up, Sammy?
>> What's going on, buddy?
Why'd you come on?
>> What's going on, man? I see I see you're
calling out William Alrich,
>> buddy. Why you want to change the topic?
I'm talking about Corin Acts 21.
>> No, I want to see how honest you are.
>> I want to see how honest you are. Don't
try to come
>> 21.
>> Jake, don't act don't act tough here,
brother.
>> About Acts 21.
>> Yeah, because Cora mentioned Acts 21:26.
Do you know what I'm talking about,
Jack?
>> What does that have to do with me?
>> Yeah, that's right. What does it So,
what are you doing here?
>> I'm here because you're challenging
William Albrech on his bad arguments,
but you don't challenge people like
Avery who use fake quotes,
>> buddy.
Why are you guys picking on Avery?
What's your problem, Jake?
>> Because if he uses fake quotes, he
should be called out for it, right?
>> And what's your proof? I don't know. He
uses fake quotes. I don't follow the
>> used a fake quote in a discussion with
me about Justin Martyr.
>> What was the fake quote, dude?
>> It was he read a chapter heading that
was from New Advent and pass it off as
Justin's words, which they weren't.
>> And that's your entire case against him.
A fake.
>> No, that's just that's just one examp.
there and you're blaming him for not
realizing it's not
>> No, I don't think he was reading it from
New Advent. I think he was reading
>> He just said it's from New Advent.
>> No, you're you're misunderstanding, Sam.
He said Justin Martyr says X and then he
reads what is actually a chapter heading
and it's not the word.
>> Why would it be his fault in assuming
that the chapter heading is written by
Justin Martyr? That's your best case.
What do you mean? He's not assuming it's
written by Justin Martyr. The fact is
that he
>> just said the chapter heading. So, he's
going to
>> But I don't think he was reading it from
there. I think somebody fed him the
source and he didn't know where it was
from.
>> Buddy, can you make up your mind, Jake?
Jake, let me repeat what you said. So, I
hear you. You just said want to repeat.
Be patient.
>> We can look at it. It's only 40 seconds
long.
>> Buddy, it's not looking at it. It's your
accusation of Avery. Let me repeat what
you said. He
>> link here for you. Go ahead.
>> Cut me off again, Jake.
I said I'll put the link for you. That's
all I said.
>> Do you want me to repeat what you said?
You said he quoted a fake quote from
Justin Martyr.
>> Yeah.
>> It wasn't Justin Martyr. It was the
chapter heading from New Advent. Say, I
heard you. So then how you blaming him?
How you blaming him, Jake,
>> for assuming the chapter heading would
have been something that Justin wrote in
his book and that Justin included it in
his Greek. That's not a
>> re the reason the reason is because when
he's when he's informed, let's say he
made a mistake, an honest mistake. Once
he's informed that this is not actually
Justin's words, he should come out and
say he made a mistake, right?
>> And why do you assume that he has to do
that?
>> Because just as you said earlier when
you were mentioning Armstrong as
compared to William, when somebody makes
a mistake, they're supposed to let their
audience know they made a mistake. No, I
give him a free pass. He's young and
he's learning. So why should he do that?
He saw it on the
>> he see that.
>> No, no, Jake. Jake, I know you're
trying. You're changing the subject.
Don't tap dance because I'm going to now
shushkaab you because we're going to get
into a topic. Don't run.
>> The difference between the difference
between Avery, he's young and he's
learning young and dumb. And but at the
same token,
I want to call you out from your misuse
of Justin Martyr and Ucius. Are you
ready for your shish kebab?
>> Where's my fake quote? Where did I use
the fake quote?
>> What did you say about the Holy Spirit?
>> Let me bring up the article because I
wrote it for you. I'm going to shishab
you.
>> What did you say? Friend Greggy and
Stafy. You know, remember Stafy, your
buddy?
>> You love Stafy? Come on.
>> Oh, I do. I actually like him. I do. I
think he's a little weird because he
talks about my body parts, but that's
what did you say about the Holy Spirit?
>> He says that the uh Holy Spirit was
brought into existence.
>> And what's the context of that
statement?
>> Hold up. Let me bring up the quote.
>> Let me bring it up, too. I got it right
here.
>> I'll bring it up in front of me. In
fact, hold on. Let me just get
>> Here's the problem, Sam.
>> No,
>> this is gonna really
is not your friend.
Ucibius is not your friend.
>> I know that. That's true.
>> Okay. And yet,
you take his words out of context. I
know what he says that the spirit was
brought into being. John 1:3. So did
Basil. St. Basil say the same argument.
But what's the context of that? Great.
What's the context?
>> I'm I'm get I'm pulling up the quote.
Give me a second.
>> Bring up the book for you. In fact, hold
on. I have one.
>> I will, but I'm going to read it as
well.
>> Here you go. Here it is. Right here.
>> One second.
>> There you go. Right here. There's the
book. Page 314. Right.
>> Uh again, just give me a second. I'm
just pulling it up here.
>> Let's see.
>> Yep. There's the book right here.
Everyone see I got the book, but I'm
going to show you so I don't think I'm
misquoting.
>> All right.
>> Let me get you on the Holy Spirit.
>> So you believe was a orthodox
trinitarian, right?
>> Yep. I don't judge them by later
trinitarian definitions and debates.
take them where they're at and I meet
them where they're at because he's
dealing with Marcelus. What was the
context of his debate with Marcelus?
What was he trying to
>> He was concerned that he was concerned
that Marcelus has fallen into modalism.
>> You got it. And so what does he have to
do to try to refute it to affirm the
distinction between father, son, and
spirit? Right.
>> 734. Yeah, it's on page. You said 314.
>> Yep.
>> Yeah, that's right. So,
>> exactly. So, because I had it. Okay. So
what comes right immediately before
that?
>> One second.
>> Right before 3:14 that you quoted.
>> Uh I'm going I have I'm looking in my
documents.
>> It begins at page 304. The discussion on
the Holy Spirit begins at page 304.
>> Yeah. But what does the actual quote say
that I quoted?
>> Yeah. I'm going to read the context,
buddy. I'm not I don't take
>> snipp let's read what that quote says.
>> Yeah. Well, we're going to read from the
context and all the way there. Take it
easy. Let me get the article. Take it
easy, man. You're not going anywhere.
>> And you know, you know, you know the
author. Do you know the translators of
the text agree with me and not you,
right?
>> No, actually they don't because I have
>> they do
>> them in here. Yeah, buddy. Read for me
right here. I give you the Greek first.
You speaks of the spirit as being with
the father before time. Now, I'm giving
you what this author says. Then we're
going to go to the context. We're going
to go to context. But what does the
author say about the passage I quoted?
>> We're going to get there. He is talking
about it, buddy. It's right here. He's
talking about John 1:3. And he's talking
about here using John 1:3. He's talking
about it and how people like you misread
it. Don't understand. I know what you're
referring to. And then we're going to go
to the actual quotes in context. See,
this author,
>> wait, I'm misreading I'm misreading who
you I'm also misreading the authors who
translated the text
>> just like you did with Justin Martyr.
Assuming that because an author says X,
he's correctly understood
what Justin is saying. I'm showing you
you can quote any authors. I just
quoting you another author that says
your authors are misunderstanding him.
So the appeal to authority doesn't work.
J
>> Sam, you're the one who used that
translation.
>> I know I did. And I'm going to go there
to show you that this author's
assessment of the Greek is right.
>> Okay. So did did those Let's read. Let's
read.
>> Did the two authors that you
>> Let's read a Kikuchu did to you. I know
you're scared.
>> Do they agree with me? They agree with
me.
>> Speaks of the spirit as being with the
father before time using imagery from
Daniel 7:10. The Holy Spirit to having
stood eternally. Read the Greek for me.
>> Hold on. I'm not even looking at
>> It's right here. The Greek. You won't
find it in the translation.
>> I can't read Greek. Why are you asking
me to read that?
>> Well, let me Okay, let me read it for
you. I don't know that. Take it easy,
man. Take it easy.
>> I never claimed to read Greek.
>> All right. Paristosisto
means what?
>> And I can't I can't see you now. But
>> I
can only see the actual screen. I can't
see you. But go ahead.
>> No, forget me. I'm putting the thing so
you can see it. Paristos a
holy spirit too having stood eternally.
Now they translate it always. In your
translation
they say always stood but he's telling
you always means eternally i.e. the
negation always no beginning.
So now explain to me what it means in
the context of to say that the spirit
has eternally stood before God and then
saying that the son brought him into
being.
>> Which uh which passage is this by the
way? What chapter is that?
>> All right, let me go to my article. Let
me get the article, buddy. Take it easy,
man. You came at the wrong time.
>> I want to bring it up in this book. So,
>> yeah, I know. I'm trying to get It's
from pages 304 to 3:14. Let me open up
my article that I quote so I can find
it. Be patient, my friend. I love you,
man. I love you, my brother. Humanity. I
swear. Just let me get there because you
came at the last minute here. This is
the book you have against Marcellus and
Ecclesiastical theory. All right.
>> Correct. Three. I'm on page 304, you
said. Correct.
>> Yeah. 3042314.
But hold on. Hold on.
>> Yeah.
>> We're going to read context.
There you go. Now I'm going to go find
it here. They translate and I'm going to
go to the book itself. According to the
same line of reasoning, the Holy Spirit
to having always stood and then I put in
parentheses the Greek or having stood
eternally. Paristos. Now let me get the
book. I'm gonna find the book for you.
Hold on, brother. My brother humanity.
Shoot, man. What's up? Let me get it,
man. Too many pages open. Take it.
>> Just confirm Sporel and Vincent agree
with my interpretation. Correct.
>> No, I have to go reread what they said.
Be careful, dude. I can't just say yes
or no. I have to read.
>> I'll give I'll give you the quote from
the same book. You have it right there.
>> Okay. Yeah. And then we'll read it in
context to see what they said. But let
me get the book itself, man. Shoot, bro.
Shoot. Let me get the book, homie. No, I
even lost the book. Damn it. Where the
hell is the book? It's right here. Okay.
According to the same Here it is. Page
307. Open it up. it for me.
>> One second. Uh 307
starting at uh at and at another time.
>> At another time. And at another time,
>> I'm looking at that. And at another
time, he revealed this about himself
through a parable, saying, "A swer went
out to sew. For from what place did he
go forth, if not from the inmost realms
of the paternal divinity?" According to
the same line of reasoning, the Holy
Spirit too, having always stood by the
throne of God.
>> You see that phrase?
>> You want me to stop?
>> No, because that's what you want to see
if I quote it correctly. Having always
stood.
>> Having always stood by the throne of
God.
>> Yeah. What's the word always? That was
the Greek word that I gave you.
>> Okay. But what does that have to do with
what these guys are saying here?
>> It means that he is unccreated. That's
the point.
>> So, how do you
>> Hold on. Let me Okay, let me give you
the 30 so I don't think I'm making it up
because I don't
>> Go ahead. I'm not cutting you off. Go
ahead.
>> No, I'm just saying I don't want you to
think I'm making.
>> So, it's hard to tell when you're
talking.
>> Go ahead.
>> Sorry, brother. So, okay, brother.
Humanity. This why I like you when
you're nice, dude. Shoot. Why can't we
be nice?
>> I'm always nice guy, Sam. He's just
>> I don't know, man. You You take some
shots, man. You've taken some shots.
>> Yeah. Well, you've taken plenty of
shots, Sam. Boss, if you go back to it,
I don't start stuff. People egg me on
and I begin. Now, here here it is.
First, you speaks of the spirit as being
with the father before time using
imagery from Daniel 7:10. The Holy
Spirit to having stood eternally. Did
you catch it? The phrase I means before
time.
>> Uh yeah, they have in the text in Daniel
7 there.
>> What is Yes. Because he's saying that
when Ucibius mentions the spirit
standing, he's saying unlike the others,
he has eternally stood before the throne
of God. This is the context and the
Greek confirms it. Paristos ai before
time. So explain to me how the spirit
can be brought into being if he is
before time. This is the Greek of
Ucibius.
>> Uh because many author Go ahead.
>> No, no, go ahead. Explain it. I was
waiting.
>> Yeah. Many authors had this idea that uh
the son or the holy spirit or both were
brought into existence before the
creation of the world for the purpose of
creation. That's a very common belief.
>> Not necessarily correct. When they say
brought into being, no, they didn't
believe. They were brought into being.
They came out of God.
But the
>> uh go ahead.
>> No, no, I'm saying I know what you're
talking about. The view of the anti-nine
fathers was the word the reason in God
as well as the spirit were in him. They
came out of him not from nothing. So
it's not a creation.
This is why it can be said that the
spirit has always timelessly stood
before God. So explain that to me.
>> I just gave you my explanation. No,
that's not an explanation because you
argued
to be brought into being.
>> Uh, no. Go ahead.
>> No, go ahead. Go ahead.
>> Yeah. So, the passage that I quoted
literally says he would be the maker and
fashioner, speaking of Christ the son of
all created things, both visible and
invisible, and surely also of the very
existence of the counseling spirit, for
all things were made through him. So how
is that not how is that a misquote?
>> Yes, because there's a distinction
created, right?
>> Very easy. No, there's a distinction
between something being brought into
existence from nothing
but something being brought forth out of
something. So when the sun
is said to have brought the spirit into
being, it's not exhil.
So he's affirming the filioquay.
This is why you went to 3:14. But if you
read him in context and read him
earlier, he is quite clear to
distinguish the spirit quote unquote
coming to being from creatures that are
created from nothing. The spirit is of
God. That's why he has eternally stood
before God. So the coming into quote
unquote being is not an act of creating
something non-existent.